[音楽]
by バーン
ua こーわー怖い怖
yankee yankee 韓辭典ヤンキーがはう気をつけて音が聞こえて使いまし
た
ペット姉マこんばんわはじめシャツ後
[音楽]
ブービー一緒に心霊スポット行ったんですけど
サティブーブー一緒に4 pot リッターカヌーけっ車がきゅんハァハァし
拍手するとかじゃね今度はウザかったんですねもう阿部なかった村てもう国道で普通に
1分
やばー止まり幼かったんですね待って返す全然新しいんですよ
ナチュラルってやつですねそれが原因かわかんないんですけどもっとエーカー後輩と
今回また線れスポットを攻めていこうと思いますで今回からですねちょっと静岡県
られまして静岡じゃないところ攻めようという話ておりは4
待つと後ろことがありましてはいと言うけど今回行って場所は小城つづっ壁
ございます赤ちゃん動物って法ザ里田前の由来がありましてですね
8ムチ塚と呼ばれるちょっと変わった名前の心霊スポットですこのおめつは紙おむつの
ことではなくておめちゃん
という女性の名前が由来になっています昔この地には嫁入り前には松屋に挨拶をしに
行かなければならないし聞いたりがありますか
松屋って何と超されている
減らしたねどんなところかであるんだ小屋番だと思うなるほどね市場でしか金さあ
みたいな拮抗する前にヒカキンさんのとこにあり付け読売が決まったを打つも四角い
さんに挨拶に行ったのだがその美貌に書にさんは目を奪われて強引に
服を脱がしてしまいましたん
しかしでしょ北京様の一位の奴イメージですけどね当時の村尾ユーチューバーである
朝日書に冷めてにあってオムツは必死にそのヒカキンさんを振りほどき
なんとか逃げましたでも諦めることができなかったヒカキンさんはおむつを自分のもの
にしようと牢屋に閉じ込めてしまいました
ヒカキンさんは1球度となくオムツに関係を迫ったが拒否されるばかり
おむつは残忍な周知を与えられ
またすでにトップヘビはムカデなども君のある生き物と一緒に1球目にされて息絶えて
しまったと
nv がこれだけ時計その事実を知ったおむつの母はやばお墓をつけて
それから数字千葉主将会は原因不明の死を遂げたと
というお話でその時近くに住んでた人の話によると
松屋さんがねあ少し前から気が狂ってシェアを上げたり暴れたりしていたらしくて一
さん見て死ぬ前にはですね
家族や嫌い全員生き方ができるこのしてたらしいこれがねそのを別の祟りだた恐れかな
支部しているとは一味にあった場所を柄にしちょっと無理
作って供養したと今から行くところはその柄でしょうか
新しいルートでご案内します有難う御座いまだないけどはその of sun の柄で
ございます怖いねこれだけ聞くと
に怖いですね結構高めたんですよ堀と高レベルな場所なんで場所が強いんですけども
今回そのを鞭使うで言ってると思いますじゃあさっそくございますか
ああああああ
pou dou dou
中部てるー
[音楽]
ブーバーあれちゃんっ
バトル操作が龍之介っていうのはいいですね女の子だったらだけだねぇ
どこだったらばたぞ高くっきた子だったりと思います
おったことうわあああっヒッサた悪くてきちっもうつきますよ
おいっにパって来られて音の準備が
目的地ですねネットの声がすごく大雑把
はいというわけでちょっと1回止めて歩いてその束を探していくことですじゃあ行き
ますか
またこれだ
public してるッえっ
どちら喋った条の2することを訴えます
うんここは右にわかりますね
佐内小道だよ
そうだ
ありえないですよね
た
すごいて別
なんかどんどんキコーナキかません
こういう聞こえましたよあんな心
聞こえるアこわいんだけど本当に到着到着しました
あ一気に変わった一気に雰囲気ががらっと変わりました
ここのどこかに柄があると言うけ
さあいきましょうんですよね
サブ機やすごいんだけども
2回骨ん
こんな時間になっ
ついてくれている
違うとじゃないですか
せません何もないんであの lc くらい吸ってーしますか
すまん
音もって本当にこんな時間に
とっ
ん
休憩んですかん
[音楽]